today we're doing reynolds number
famous number named after reynolds talks
about fluid mechanics to do with navier
stokes equations but it's not one number
it's not like pi it's not no no this is
this is like the superhero version of pi
because pi is fixed pi has like one
super power like circles and things this
is reynolds number this guy can
morph and change to be whatever value it
wants to be
but depending on what sort of size it is
whether it's really big or really small
you get different behavior with your
fluid
so it's more like a label that you give
to a particular situation you have a
fluid moving in some setup and that's
like high reynolds number it does one
thing but if you have the same fluid
moving in a slightly different set up
where it's now got a low reynolds number
it does something completely different
like choosing your superhero from the
avengers if it needs to be invisible it
can be invisible if it needs to reverse
time it can reverse time it can do
whatever it wants starting point navia
stokes equations so these guys model the
motion the flow of every fluid on earth
in the universe in fact so we have these
equations they come from sort of
universal laws of physics we have masses
conserved we have newton's second law
we get our equations so we'll start by
writing those guys down we talked about
these guys before and we did the full
sort of what everything means but we've
got the top one the little guy which is
conservation of mass and then we have
newton's second law
i've made another slight simplification
from the standard navier stokes and i've
said there are no body forces normally
there's a big plus f here we're going to
pretend there's not that's the simple
case so here's our navier-stokes
equations now we want to get the
reynolds number so we need to define
what the reynolds number is we label it
with re and it's going to be our density
rho times a length scale l times a
velocity u divided by
viscosity mu tom why do we even need a
reynolds number these navier-stokes
equations which you've explained to us
before
serviceable things for figuring out how
fluids work what was missing in the
first place here so so equation one is
nice and simple so we actually that guy
doesn't change with the reynolds number
discussion but equation two we've got
like three bits
so we've got use a different color so
we've got
this guy is acceleration because it's a
density times a change in velocity this
guy is a pressure and then this guy is
viscosity so viscosity is like an
internal friction your layers of fluid
sliding over one another and interacting
so we've got three bits
and the point is in different situations
some of these bits will be more
important than others practical example
is if viscosity was important when you
go fast you could clean your car by
driving really quickly well the air will
just blast off exactly so if you have
loads of little bits of mud all over
your car you just drove really fast the
air would actually wash it off because
the friction in the air would grab onto
the dirt particles clean your car for
you so viscosity doesn't matter if
you're going fast it turns out as we're
going to see because of the reynolds
number in some situations they're all
equally important
but in certain situations like the
extreme cases
you can get that one of them doesn't
actually matter or one of them is so
important that dominates the other two
and then you've got a nice simpler
equation
which we can then solve because as we
know we can't always solve navier sticks
so if we can get our hands on this
reynolds number allows us to simplify
them and actually solve them and get
somewhere so the reynolds number is what
apportions different weightings to the
different factors exactly exactly
[Music]
[Music]
we can either have a really big reynolds
number or really small i know it's not
the sort of the standard thing we do in
maths let's consider if it's really big
or it's really small and just so i've
got some idea of what numbers you're
talking about we're talking like
billions and negative numbers like tell
us where they are so the result has to
be positive because it's a density times
a length times a velocity over a
viscosity these are all positive
physical things you can measure and you
plug those values in you'll get a number
so it can be as small as sort of you can
write down towards zero so you know
can't be zero just above zero
or it can go as big as you want but
generally we're talking sort of ten to a
thousand
most everyday situations if it's over a
thousand it's turbulent so turbulence is
this chaotic crazy motion of fluids
crashing into each other so we have two
cases the reynolds number we've got big
reynolds number so we say it's not just
greater than one it's much greater than
one so sort of a thousand and above
turbulence and your equations
so we've got rid now
of all of the sort of these guys like
the mu and the row they've sort of
they're in the reynolds number now so
they're gone and so what that means is
you can start to compare your terms
and you end up with this guy one over
reynolds
square
so if we compare this one to our
original equation we have the same terms
we've still got acceleration we've still
got pressure and we've still got
viscosity but now we've sort of got rid
of all the other little bits that were
floating around and now we can compare
everything because by introducing the
reynolds number what we've done is we've
non-dimensionalized the system which
means get rid of the units if i say i
have 10 apples and i have 9 bananas then
if we consider apples
i have more fruit with my 10 apples than
i do with my nine bananas but with my
nine bananas i have more potassium than
i do with my apples the units matter it
depends you can't say i have more apples
than bananas
it depends whether i'm talking about
fruit or potassium the units are
important so now by introducing the
reynolds number what we've done is a
non-dimensionalization and we've got rid
of units so now we can compare
acceleration pressure and viscosity
three very different things with
different units but now they have no
units if the number associated with the
acceleration term is bigger than the
number associated with pressure that
means acceleration is bigger than
pressure it makes sense to compare them
because they have no units anymore okay
this is this is the power of the
reynolds number really does the reynolds
number itself have units then the
reynolds number does not have units the
reynolds number is just a number and we
can actually
see that so the reynolds number itself
is density times length times speed
divided by viscosity so let's think
about the units that's a real hot
portrait units it is so density that's
going to be
kilograms per meter cubed so we're in 3d
so we use the square bracket notation to
denote units
for our length well that's just in
meters
our velocity
u
that's in meters per second
and then our viscosity
so this one is possibly less well-known
but this guy is kilograms per meter per
second and now if we plug them all
together in the reynolds number formula
we get the re the units so on the top
we've got a density so it's a kg
m minus three then we've got a length
that's an m then we've got a speed m s
minus one
and then we divide through by
viscosity and now hopefully we've done
this right kilograms cancel meters
meters meters minus three gives us
meters minus one cancels second times
one six minus one so the reynolds number
has no units brilliant so it is just a
number that's why it's called reynolds
number it does it's just a number it's
why we can think about what happens when
it's big
and get this equation so now the
reynolds number is really big we've got
acceleration equals pressure plus one
over a really big number
times viscosity
so one divided by a really big number is
really small so what's that telling us
is that that guy
doesn't matter
so in the situation of really large
reynolds numbers which could be
very very light very very high density
very very long fluids or very very fast
fluids so make any you can just make
this thing big however you have to
viscosity doesn't matter so you're
driving your car you're going really
really fast that's why the viscosity of
the air doesn't clean the dirt from your
car because you're in this large
reynolds number and your equations say
viscosity doesn't matter so it doesn't
it doesn't work so what if the reynolds
number is now really really small we say
it's much less than one it's not just
smaller one it's much less than one and
so what happens now with our equations
is when we substitute this in we do our
non-dimensionalization the same way as
before
but now
we've got reynolds number times
acceleration
equals
the pressure term
plus the viscosity term
so now it's slightly different to the
one we had so we've got reynolds number
just a number times acceleration is
pressure plus viscosity you might be
wondering why is the reynolds number now
here why is it on acceleration when
before we had it over on viscosity now
we have a small reynolds number and so
in a small reynolds number flow we sort
of know we've done experiments to say
that the pressure term is actually
balanced by viscosity
whereas in the big reynolds number case
the pressure term is balanced
by the acceleration
so that there is some
slight difference in how you
non-dimensionalize
but
it still works in the same way it still
has units of pressure you just have this
choice between how to balance your
pressure so when the renal number is
small we have this guy so it's reynolds
times acceleration is pressure plus
viscosity
but the renaissance was really really
small so now i've got a tiny number
times acceleration so acceleration
doesn't matter because reynolds number's
really small so that now goes so this is
the term that doesn't matter in this
small reynolds number
regime so now just we've got pressure
and viscosity and that's it our
governing equation
is just pressure gradient plus viscosity
my favorite thing i'm going to say in
all of fluids is getting this result
because
we no longer have time
in our equations
so we've started with navier stokes
which we know are true mass is conserved
newton's second law that's a given then
we've looked at small reynolds number
and it turns out that in that situation
time vanishes from our equations because
the only thing bringing time to the
table was acceleration exactly the only
possible t in our equations was in the
acceleration term so now that's gone it
doesn't matter i mean it's still there
but it doesn't matter it's everything
else is bigger than it so they dominate
so what that tells us is that when you
have a small reynolds number
time doesn't matter
so if you go forwards in time
and then you do the exact same thing
backwards in time and it has to be the
same thing because the pressure and the
velocity have to still be the same but
if you go forwards and then you go
backwards
you should get back to where you started
you can literally time travel
you can time travel in a fluid because
your reynolds number is small and
because time has vanished from your
equation so how do we get
small reynolds number we've got density
times length times velocity divided by
viscosity let's make viscosity big
if we divide by a really big number
reynolds number becomes small a large
viscosity means a very thick sticky
fluid let's take corn syrup sugar syrup
your favorite type of syrup it's very
thick it's very sticky very large
viscosity so now we have a small
reynolds number so let's see if we can
do an experiment
and get the same thing as we go forwards
in time and then backwards in time
because the equations say
it should work here is a cylindrical
container filled with sugar syrup we're
going to add three drops of food
coloring
and then if we slowly turn this stirrer
to mix the fluids together
we go forwards in time so we'll do
several rotations
and then stop and as you can see the
blobs of food dye have mixed together as
you might expect now if we do the exact
same thing in reverse so the same speed
the same pressure everything the same
but we reverse the direction of our
stirrer we're going backwards in time
and as you can see
it's magic
voila we have gone back to the very
beginning we have gone mixed them
together for us in time and then gone
backwards in the exact same way and
return to our original state and this
works because time is not in our
governing equations so without navia
stokes without reynold's number without
this knowledge
we wouldn't know to even try this
experiment you wouldn't know to pick a
really sticky fluid and see this awesome
thing happening but it is explained by
the fact that time
disappears from our equations and that
came from reynolds number what's the
bonus or the cool thing about a really
big reynolds number big reynolds numbers
so big reynolds numbers just means super
turbulent flow
so so large reynolds number is any any
kind of aerodynamics flow around a
formula one car flow around a jet that's
large reynolds number flow and the issue
with large rentals number flow
is
well turbulence
and turbulence totals we don't
understand tobins is one of the reasons
we don't understand navier stokes and
one of the possibly one of the ways of
getting that million dollar millennium
problem prize is by trying to actually
come up with a theory for turbulence so
large reynolds number flows
turbulence very very difficult but
fortunately smaller number flows
make a bit more sense and the sort of
the intricate maths to it or the key bit
of the maths is that
when you have the small reynolds number
as well as losing time
we we lose time because we lose the
acceleration term
but the acceleration term
is non-linear
and so what that means is that's the
difficult bit of narrower stokes the
reason navier stokes are such a hard set
of equations to solve is because they're
non-linear so that means if you have one
solution solution a and you have a
second solution b for a linear equation
a plus b will also satisfy that equation
but navier stokes is non-linear so when
you do a plus b you don't get a solution
anymore and that's because that's how we
generally solve difficult partial
differential equations difficult
differential equations in general we
find one solution find one that's
similar to it and keep adding them all
together and you get all of the
solutions but we can't do it because
navier-stokes is non-linear
but it's only nonlinear for big reynolds
number if we take small reynolds number
we've lost acceleration we've lost time
we've lost non-linearity
and then we can actually solve it and
and get
interesting solutions unfortunately
that's not a very practical thing that
doesn't happen very often in the real
world it doesn't no so
reynolds numbers
generally in the real world
like most things are turbulent right if
you just think the wind
the water in a river in an ocean it's
most of our interactions with fluids are
turbulent or are at least 100 plus on
the reynolds number scale this kind of
thing getting rid of the nonlinear bit
getting rid of time like you need less
much less than one so you don't really
see that in most of our world you would
on a tiny little like bacteria scale
you think about you know what's going on
on the really small cell like individual
cell scale you might start to get small
enough length scales in your reynolds
number that it'll become small but in
our world unfortunately we live in a
turbulent world
and we don't understand turbulence we
live in a two with the world and that's
the truth
voltage difference which essentially
means you need a bunch of positive
charges here and a bunch of negative
charges here and then the things sort of
fairly catastrophically re-equalize and
the charges all balance out by a spark
of electricity essentially a current
flying from one to the other to make the
thing all equalise out